this is part five of the completely free
arcad course if you're new here firstly
my name is David tomich I'm a registered
architect here in Western Australia and
today we're talking about doors and
windows in archicad if this is the first
episode you're watching jump back to
part one catch up to where we are and
let's dive in to part five to continuing
the progress on from part 4 where we
left off without all of our walls
completed we're going to jump down to
our ground floor plan so on the ground
floor plan as you can see it's clearly
just Windows there's not much going on
whatsoever so we're going to make it a
little bit more exciting a little bit
more entertaining first of all let's
start with our door tool if we select
the door and then click on the settings
icon alternatively you can press command
T to open it up or control T if you're
on Windows we can see we have our doors
available to us we can start by using
our folder structure which allows us to
see all of the doors available to us and
above that in our link to libraries we
have empty door openings garage doors
hinge doors and so forth we can
obviously look through all of these one
by one to find the perfect door that
we're looking for alternatively we can
create some favorites as well or last of
all we can simply search by typing in
door or if you know the door that you're
specifically looking for let's do it the
old school way let's do it the long way
just to Showcase all the parts for you
guys first of all we're going to hit
that chair icon which is your main
folder structure and embedded libraries
I personally do use the 4D library
because I find their doors and windows
significantly better but because these
come free with archicad we're not going
to dive into any paid extras we're just
going to use what is available to most
people around the world so our front
door is obviously going to be a hinge
door in this scenario it could be a
pivot it could be a sliding but let's
stick to hinge door for this if you
scroll down to find door 26 that is your
most basic door possible it is just a
typical rectangle door hinged on one
side nothing special on either side you
can see there's a million and one
options of different styles transoms
highlights Etc but we're going to use
this and we're going to move through it
one by one so let's revert back to the
very first of the drop down menu and go
through this one by one up the top what
you're going to see is very similar to
the walls and the slab it is pretty
consistent through our icad so the width
of the door the height of the door the
seal to the story zero if you're unaware
of what the seal is if you're looking at
a door it is the Threshold at the very
bottom same for Windows the windows is
the bottom is the seal the top is the
head and the sides of the jamb they're
just technical architectural terms that
you'll get familiar with over time
they're revealed to the wall core is
basically how far in or out it pushes it
against the wall so if you're using
double brick need to close the cavity
off you'd use this setting to adjust on
the right hand side here you have five
different icons that basically highlight
what this door looks like in different
viewports so you obviously have your
plan view you have your elevation view
you have the 3D model you have it
rendered out and then you just have some
generic information about the door
itself typically I'll flick through the
first three just to understand what it
looks like some planned you I know
what's showcased elevation and 3D for
the very purposes of this you don't need
to go into too much detail of
understanding all of these Dimensions
but when you do get into some technical
architectural detailing all of this will
be critically important especially
depending on the doors you actually
select because when you come to
dimensioning at the very end all of this
will be critical and if you go and
change your door style your jams your
door widths whatever all of these will
change change slightly so you want to
get familiar with this later on but not
for now if we slowly click through we
can go to our door settings and openings
so first of all door Leaf one we can
choose from a million well almost a
million 60 available styles to us from
archicad as default which is pretty much
all the doors available to us from your
local hardware store or your local door
supplier so you can select any one of
these that you like for the purpose of
this I'm going to go to HV grid just to
be able to actually articulate a few
more elements of these settings if I now
go to Elevation you'll see that's
changed completely if I wanted to add a
door handle as well to increase the 3D
appearance of this let's simply click
door handle one away we go you can
change the opening type and the frame
type as well you can also increase
natural ventilation which adds basically
a little bit of a gap at the top you
don't need to worry about natural
ventilation for the purpose of this it
is more of a construction detailing
process as you get more familiar with
icad now we could click this little icon
here to jump ahead and adjust all of
these HP grids but I'm going to get to
that a little bit later and slowly tap
through it one by one the framer Leaf
provides you the ability to change the
actual frame itself a 27 millimeter
frame is actually quite small but I'm
not going to adjust it I'm not too
worried about it just note that you can
change the external frame here if you
wanted so if I wanted to smash that up
to 100 you'd see a very big profile
created I'll drop that back 27 and
continue with this
moving to Natural ventilation same as
what we ticked before you can tick it
untick it door Leaf style is where we
would have jumped ahead if we were
indoor settings so if I hit this button
it would automatically jump to Door Leaf
style which gives us a little bit more
control of the actual HP grid so for
example we can change our actual sizes
of the leaf the lower 200 I'm going to
adjust that back down to 100 just so
it's continuous all the way around the
grid width and thickness is defining
these mullions in between on the glass
so if you wanted to increase them you'd
see they jump up quite significantly and
you can change a position to either one
side or not throughout basically means
they're going to cut each individual
square of glass to size of these whereas
if you go inside or outside they're
basically just going to stick them on
again more of a detailing thing not too
important at this point in time now the
reason I selected HB grid is because it
allows us a lot more flexibility here so
we can change this to five we can change
it to two we can change it back four or
whatever we seriously want want it to
look like because now we have a lot more
control so if I change it to four and
two I can get quite a nice door
happening moving on to the handle
settings again very similar you can kind
of adjust the height so you can adjust
the position you can change your handle
and you can add a kickboard not too
important and continuing on again more
settings that aren't really too
important at the moment so for example
if we wanted to change that from 90
degrees opening to 45 we could change
that here and the same goes for the 3D
in 3D currently it will only be shown as
completely closed but we can open that
up if we want to the next settings are
more to do again with documentation not
too much to be worried about as a
beginner we can get back to that later
on as we dive deeper model attributes is
somewhere you're going to want to stop
so if we click on this little 3D icon
you'll see Andor is pretty white there's
not much going on there's not much
happening whatsoever let's say we wanted
to change it to a nice black Monument
door so by obviously selecting on the
side arrow and selecting a different
color it automatically change because I
have uniform door surfaces ticked it
will automatically change everything at
once to make sure it is consistent I'm
happy with that personally I don't want
to go through everything one by one so I
have no issues with changing all the
frames to Monument in this case the leaf
glass again I'm happy to leave this
clear otherwise you can change that to
frosted mirrored satin whatever you
really want so now we can switch back to
our elevation or our floor plan view
because we know what the door is going
to look like we don't have to worry too
much further as we continue to move
through the settings we're going to get
to our reviews and our door edges this
is how it works against the actual wall
itself for the purpose of this I don't
really want to reveal I'm not too
worried about it being anything special
but you can change these for the
architectural look and feel masonry
arches are a little bit more technical
but they're quite easy you simply
increase it change the style and you'll
get some sort of masonry head on top of
your window or door for me personally I
don't want to make something else at all
I'm going to keep that unticked and move
forward when we get into fixtures and
fittings this becomes a little bit more
architectural a little bit more detailed
but it gives you a lot to actually
consider and this is what makes a door
so detailed and so important so we can
we start talking about our casing
gaining thresholds sun shades seals Etc
if we were to go in and start clicking
on bits and pieces you'd see what
happens individually as we start ticking
if we were to tick the threshold it
means we're crossing over from an
internal to an external how we want that
threshold to look we can adjust that in
here and these are all construction
details that you just need to be aware
of at this time that they exist but you
don't have to worry about it from a
presentation point of view where we get
into some serious architectural
detailing of doors and windows and you
know specifically what you're going to
install this is where you're going to be
spending a little bit of time especially
if you want to seal for example and you
want all that water to run off the
bottom or you want a little ramp or
anything like that these details are
very very important and you want to
spend some time on them as you go
through however for us we're not going
to worry about any of them so we're
going to keep clicking through and
you'll see more and more options
available for each individual setting
the sun shade is something a lot of
people do use for General Aesthetics and
just like doors you have a few options
that you can choose from so if you're
building maybe a beach hut or a Beach
Shack and you want to close off those
windows where nobody's home it's a very
simple way to put some sun shades on if
you have any of those elements ticked
you will then activate the model
attributes for all of them which allows
you to change the colors very similar to
what we did for the door when we get to
the floor plan and section detailed
views personally I just hate the orange
even though it is the correct setting
and it is the right line weight and
everything I just absolutely hate it so
I tend to just simply change that to the
same line weight in Black so I don't
have to look at it continuously if you
don't want to go through changing every
single item to Black and slowly changing
bits and pieces like we just have done
there
what you can do is simply come to the
bottom overwrite the line weight select
change it to Black override the object
pen as well now everything will
automatically be changed to Black so you
don't have to actually worry about
changing individual colors if these are
ticked these you can change a million
times over and nothing will happen until
you untick these continually along it's
providing a minimal space diagram these
are for your standards to make sure that
it actually complies with clearances so
you can adjust these to suit actual
Australian standards disability
clearances access and egress however
this different for every single country
every single state in some countries so
you just have to recognize this is very
specific to your area tags and labeling
is something we're going to get onto a
little bit later on it is to identify
our doors and windows I personally like
to just come back and update all the
tags when already rather than try and
continuously updated as I'm moving along
because you just spend way too much time
trying to do that last but not least you
have your description and all of your
extra bits and pieces so for instance if
you want to do a bill of quantities
through archicad and you knew this door
was going to cost you two thousand
dollars to install paint everything you
could drop that figure in there and
eventually it would spit out all of your
information if you want to you can
introduce all the manufacturers
locations details in here which is going
to spit out the information at the very
end on the door and windows schedule but
then again we'll get to that at the very
specific time when we need to so all
these description features not too
important best thing now is you can
actually press OK all these settings are
good to go you can simply drag your door
in Click once click again and press the
escape button now if we go into 3D
you'll see the door is all black and we
are missing all of that glass and all of
that detail now you might be thinking
what's going on why is it doing that
number of reasons it is based on the
actual model settings we want to make
this look fantastic so let's open it up
let's come back into our model
attributes and simply change 3D detail
level from model to full and press ok
now we have all of that detail that we
originally included into that door if we
come back into our floor plan and select
our window tool this time we can do a
very very similar scenario here all of
these settings are basically identical
to what we've just gone through in the
door settings so I'm not going to go
through everyone individually again it
is just going to be an absolute bore and
a waste of time the only one that is
different is your custom corner now your
custom Corner if you tick the corner one
or two it's simply going to slice that
corner directly at a 90 degree angle by
default which means you can then connect
two corners against the side of a wall
so let's do two things first of all
let's come into our model attributes
let's change this to Black so it matches
our door now let's zoom into our bedroom
hover over one of our walls making sure
our sun icon is where the sun is coming
from so you don't want the sun to be
inside you want the sun to be on the
outside click once and then we can move
our Mouse left to right to indicate
where we want that corner so by hovering
over the left hand side you'll see that
corner column is present on the actual
right hand side where the corner needs
to be tapping Escape command or control
d i can shift that window all the way to
the corner holding my option on my alt
button
I can repeat that same process to
reintroduce another window in the corner
now if I select one of those windows
select the black hotspot I can make it
two and a half meters wide and then I
can replicate the same here so click on
the hotspot and just simply start typing
two and a half thousand press enter
coming back into 3D
you'll see we've created that corner
window right there on the edge now I
hate this corner window it doesn't look
right it doesn't fit to the actual
architecture Aesthetics so let's first
of all command T open it up double click
on these two overrides down the bottom
and change it to 21 black now we've got
black lines everywhere which is exactly
what we're looking for we're going to
jump to our sash options and change that
to a HV grid very similar to our door
two vertically and I want to have three
horizontally and then I'm simply going
to press ok now just like before we've
introduced all those additional elements
but they're not showing up
we have two options here we can go back
into our window and adjust the model
view settings or we can come down to the
bottom to our actual model view settings
where it says zero one site
if I select zero one site you'll notice
that a number of different options come
up
as you progress and slowly get more and
more detailed you adjust all of these
settings to reflect the information you
need
personally I like to see a lot of
information I'm very detail orientated
so let's hit construction and you'll see
all of the model settings instantly
change all elements this is a great way
to make sure you're always getting all
of the information you need so even
though we upgraded this to full
previously we weren't getting the hinged
indicators in 3D and we weren't getting
the handle and on our windows we weren't
getting these HV lines at all so now
that we've changed this to construction
we're a lot better off and we can see a
lot more if we want to make sure that
this is continuous we can simply hit the
settings button go get current settings
View and press ok so every time we go
back to 3D it's going to Showcase what
we want to see now if we come back to
the ground floor we can repeat this same
process for all the internal doors all
the extra windows and all the extra bits
and Bobs so I'll stop talking for a
minute and I'll quickly speed through
all of these internal and external doors
now if you do want this archicad file
you can jump down to the patreon down
below below sign up jump onto our
Discord chat and access every single
course part individually per arcad file
so you can cross reference your model to
what I've done
so what I've done is quickly gone
through and just added a ton of windows
and doors to our actual design on the
ground floor what I want to do is simply
start adjusting a few things now to make
them work so selecting that door let's
make it 2400 Tall select in this window
I only want it to be about 600 wide
command D allows me to move it in 3D and
I want it to be perfectly aligned next
to this door I also want to stretch out
the actual height of the window so
eating one of the hot spots stretch
vertically and dragging down allows us
to move it to a bit more of a reasonable
size I can repeat that same step align
it drag it drop it and then if I want
this window and this window to look the
same I can hold option and then hold
option command to actually drop them and
align them then I can continue moving
all of my elements around updating my
door window sizes as I see fit and there
we go now we have all of our Windows
ready to go onto the ground floor plan
this is going to be our carport and
that's where our stairs are going to be
so I haven't dragged any Windows into
that section what we're going to do now
is come up to our top floor plan and
actually introduce some more creative
Windows some bifolds some louvers
something a little bit more technical a
little bit more detailed so let's jump
back to our ground floor plan command up
to jump to our top floor what I actually
want to do is drag this back into our
staircase because I don't want that
there so I'm going to select all these
walls option G to ungroup select my blue
line go to my offset tool and then drag
that approximately back there I can then
reduce that section A lot bigger and
increase the size of this overall space
you can actually fit something and nice
and reasonable on this side now whereas
previously you couldn't so let's focus
on these balconies as the main critical
point first of all let's say I want some
sort of little planter box here to
really give the elevation articulation
some life it's first we're going to
design a little planter box and then
we're going to design a retractable
luver screen so let's hold the option
button
copy this wall across hit P just like we
learned before let's make that about two
meters wide drag that back in although
selecting those two walls again command
T we don't want to link them at all and
we only want to make them about a meter
high coming back into 3D you'll see
we've adjusted a few bits and pieces
we've created our planter box what we
are missing is the actual first floor
slab which I haven't created on purpose
because we're going to keep adjusting
this up floor until it's just right and
then we'll add it a little bit later on
but for the purpose of this we've
created that little planter box we want
to create one more wall on this side and
we want to link it back in to this side
now you might be thinking we've just
created a big slab of wall on this side
that does absolutely nothing but that's
how we're actually going to create one
of our custom bifolding screens so let's
jump back into our door tool let's open
up our door settings let's go to Sliding
and folding doors we can either select
the bifold or the folding door whichever
one we really want for this instance I'm
probably just going to go the single
bifolding door and have it all pushed to
one side now this is where it gets
creative and where we get a little bit
more technical so let's keep this HP
grid on let's directly jump to the HV
grid settings we want to drop all of
these to 50 millimeters and make it a
very thin profile ideally if we do it
out of steel we might even be able to
get away with 40 millimeters so we can
drop that quite thin next we want to
next we want to change our actual panel
grid layout vertically we don't want any
we just want to hit that to zero which
will automatically default to one
horizontally is another scenario we want
to bump that up until we are roughly
happy with the look of it so as the
doors increase they will change I've
adjusted it to appropriately where I see
fit press OK let's drag and drop this
door into the scenario and then what
we're going to need to do is actually
extend it all the way across so command
T opens it up once more
it's about four meters wide so I want to
have five doors and then I want to
probably have eight or nine horizontal
mullions nine might look a little bit
better than eight lastly we're going to
come into our model view settings we're
going to change everything to the same
color let's pick a nice wood texture so
let's go a nice horizontal Walnut and
then for the glass which is all the
individual spaces in between we just
simply want to hit air which gets rid of
everything in between now personally I
still think the width of this grid is a
little bit thin so if I bump that up to
50 maybe 40 to match the rest of it and
press ok then I can come back into 3D
and adjust the door where it needs to be
these are just simply louvers so I'm
going to increase that to 300 and I'm
going to offset that 300 from the top so
simply typing in 300 tapping the minus
button we get what we want to see and
you see these louvers are now created if
you don't want them to be opening in 3D
jump back into our settings go to
opening type and width width in 3D
simply hit zero and we have a fully
closed system now we can repeat that
same step for this side section here
because it's only two eight we don't
need as many doors we'll drop that down
to three doors press ok go back into 3D
and you'll see we have our screen
created relatively quickly now because
our doors are opening on the outside
what we also got to be very mindful of
is a balustrade if we were to open these
doors people would fall relatively
quickly and hurt themselves so we don't
want to do that if we want to put a
balustrate in but we'll get to that a
little bit later on on this side of the
stairs we also want to replicate
something very similar but we just want
to make that a window so if we dive back
down to our bedroom grab one of these
Corner windows or even let's grab this
game's room window come to the stairs
drop that in all the way adjust it to
full length come into 3D
make sure it is the same height as our
bifold doors over here open up our
settings go to the HB grid change the
number of grids so vertically we want
one horizontally we're going to need a
few so let's go 50 maybe 40 and adjust
that width to 40 as well so overall I'm
happy with that all I need to do is
change from black to Walnut press OK and
then architecturally looking at it from
the front we have our beautiful
bifolding doors because we don't know
what we're doing upstairs just yet we're
going to come back to that in the
objects and Furniture section of this
tutorial we're going to leave that as is
we're simply going to introduce one
window here reduce the overall length of
it and last but not least go to our
doors go to our door settings open up
our sliding doors and drop an external
sliding door into our project here now
to wrap this video up we're going to
introduce one last element so let's
select this wall that was originally our
planter box let's relink that back to
our roof plan zero zero it out press ok
go to our window tool open up our window
settings simply type in opening find a
regular square opening press OK
introduce that into our design here make
sure our seal is one meter jumping into
3D and aligning our seal height with our
window Heights over here we'll see that
we've now created an opening allowing
that lights to come through but yet
connecting our wall back to our main
house so it isn't flapping around in the
wind and we don't have the tie it across
here anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed the video if you did the
playlist design of me holds all of these
tutorials so far and all of them to come
if you loved it make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below as well as
the notification Bell but like always
I'll see you next Monday